serse benvenuti nuovissimo video ormai
lo sapete manca pochissimo al milione di
iscritti quindi mi raccomando se non
avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al mio canale e cliccate
sulla campanella vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione attivando tutte le
notifiche modo tale che tutte le volte
il pubblico un nuovo video di arrivi una
notifica e video di oggi è assolutamente
una novità per il mio canale perché non
ho mai postato un contenuto simile ma
visto che tanti di voi spesso mi mi
hanno chiesto di provare a trasformarmi
in un personaggio conosciuto in un
personaggio di una serie ho pensato che
fosse arrivato il momento di farlo è il
primo personaggio in cui ho deciso di
trasformarmi è un personaggio che io amo
di una serie che io stramo sto parlando
di rebecca di elite perché amore backup
allora essenzialmente mi piace molto il
suo stile è che si avvicina parecchio al
mio mi conoscete sapete mi piacciono le
cose poco sobrie e lei è la regina della
poca sobrietà
caratterialmente mi piace molto perché
fa molto la dura ha sempre la battuta
pronta però si vede che in realtà sotto
sotto ha un cuore molto tenero e anche
qui ci assomigliamo
quindi oggi insieme a voi cercherò di
ricreare il suo look quindi sia per
quanto riguarda lotti sia per quanto
riguarda il make up
partiamo dall'outfit allora ho cercato
appunto le foto di rebecca su google e
devo dire che ci sono parecchi outfit
che mi piacciono molto
quindi vediamo anche a seconda di quello
che trovo nel mio armadio per chi non lo
sapesse o un armadio di vestiti che uso
per uscire e un armadio rivestiti chiuso
per i video quindi magari quelli che non
metto più che sono passati di moda
travestimenti delle principesse disney
l'armadio che io chiamo del cabaret
sicuramente
dovrò andare a spulciare anche
nell'armadio del cabaret allora prima
ancora di te vedere di comporre la
outfit ho visto è una foto questi
orecchini con scrittore de ecco o degli
orecchini molto simili e non c'è scritto
rebbe ma c'è scritto baby perché da cene
se non sbaglio li ho trovati così vi
faccio vedere subito
ecco uno dei fantastici contenitori dove
si può godere kg ed ecco gli orecchini
con scritto belli cioè ragazzi dai
quadri che questa b potrebbe anche
sembrare una r
magari da lontano sembrerebbe no va bene
noi né nel dubbio scegliamoli qui ci
sono se questi che potrebbero essere da
dare vezza guarda neanche a farlo
apposta un po più piccoli ma sono molto
simili mi aveva detto che abbiamo uno
stile abbastanza simile per quanto
riguarda la outfit vedo qua parecchie
volte tipo maglia rete le gare tesi
dovrei avere qualcosa nere vado a vedere
nell'armadio del cabaret e tornò come
immaginavo ho trovato molto materiale
per l'esattezza sono tre maglie e un
topino il topino sicuramente lo
indosserò di cosa stiamo parlando è
proprio rebecca style
per quanto riguarda le maglie da
metterci sopra sono in decisa da questa
qua è un po troppo larga forse per i
miei gusti
poi c'è questa qui che è una rete però
troppo sottile vedete come tra l'altro
c'è scritto black t shirt credo di non
aver mai messa davanti ma quando le
poche volte in cui l'ho messa la giravo
in modo tale che vedete trasparente però
hanno scritto
questa è la migliore siamo messa molto
bene con questo forse è meglio che io le
indossi allora eccoci qua questo qua è
il topino che metterò sottosopra
voglio provare a mettere questa che deve
fare secondo me e dopo adesso vediamo
cosa mettere sotto allora non è
facilissimo trovare delle sue foto
intere per adesso sto vedendo georges
neri che tra l'altro non ho leggins tipo
pantaloni per fare sport e pantaloni
neri
allora jeans neri io li avete visti
anche nel nella mia jeans collection se
non l'avete ancora vista qui però tutta
nera ma se usassi il jeans sobrio sempre
della jeans collection maculato
allora prima di scegliere i pantaloni mi
sto vedendo gli orecchini e vedo di
riempire questo look con gli accessori
per poi capire quale pantalone sta
meglio tra quello nero effetto ma poi
considerate dobbiamo rivedere il make up
e i capelli lei porta però sempre anche
delle belle catena d'oro che voi direte
ma maria non ce l'avrai white ma è certo
che ho così tante catene d'oro che se
fossero oro vero sarei ricca allora c'è
questa che però non luccica come vorrei
oggi questa che è minuscola che devo
fare questa cosa questa che anche troppo
sottile quindi la mia scelta ricade su
questa che bella pacchiana come piace a
rebekah ea marina
adesso sì che ci stiamo avvicinando
adoro un'altra cosa che ha sempre
rebecca sono gli occhiali in particolare
quelli un po tipo con le lenti colorate
c'è una scena in cui ha degli occhiali
con le lenti colorate rosa e vi stupirò
vi ho anch'io
ecco qui gli occhiali con le lenti rosa
sono un'altra persona mi chiamo rebecca
quindi scegliamo questi benedetti
pantaloni allora ho fatto prima togliere
la videocamera dal cavalletto così vi
faccio vedere questo qua e il pantarei
jeans nero
non lo so me sembra troppo sobrio
proviamo quello maculato
devo dire che così è tutta un'altra
storia
c'è questa è la sobrietà
ma non è finita qui perché rebecca non è
rebecca senza i suoi marsupi e quindi
alcuni di voi se lo ricorderanno bene ho
tirato fuori la mia borsa marsupio di
gucci
adesso sì che si ragiona ragazzi questo
secondo me è un look perfetto al rebecca
quello che non è perfetto ovviamente
sono questi capelli che non c'azzeccano
niente e il make up che dobbiamo
ritoccare quindi venite con me nel mio
favoloso mondo delle trasformazioni
eccoci qui nel mio bagno dove ho tutti i
miei trucchi e dove mi trasformo riva i
personaggi che vedete sempre nei video a
loro visto che in una scena una
bellissima coda alta di lato e quindi
vorrei provare a ricreare
quell'acconciatura quindi tiro bene di
lato poi magari metterò anche un po di
lac verrà devi trani alla fine di questo
video et voilà
per quanto riguarda il make up parte che
io sono già un po truccata come potete
vedere è poco lei di base ha quasi
sempre lai liner nero e sto guardando
soprattutto nell'ultimo episodio ha
quasi
chi hai quindi all'occhio molto molto
nero e anche la matita sotto che faccio
aggiungo solo lai liner poi faccio anche
lo smoky eye ai tre secondi per darti
una risposta da sola 3 2 1 ma si dai
facciamo lo smoky eyes utilizzerò
appunto questo ombretto super nero
andando ad applicare sopra il trucco che
ho già partendo da l'esterno cercando di
sfumare verso interna adesso creò un
punto luce con vedete adesso matita nera
sia all'interno dell'occhio che è
sfumata sulla rima ciliare inferiore
ok ho utilizzato una tonalità attiva
dita per le sopracciglia più scura della
dell'amia per evidenziarle ancora di più
e adesso cosa manca un po di blush un po
di illuminante e poi le labbra rimarrei
su una tonalità nude tipo quella che ho
già fatto ed ecco qui il bluff finale
sono sconvolta perché effettivamente è
proprio look da rebekah questo è il make
up
come potete vedere o scurito bene gli
occhi news sulle labbra
quello che non sapete è che tra la scena
ho girato in bagno e quella che sto
girando adesso sono pagato 5 ore nelle
quali io ho girato tre tik tok un
monologo ovviamente su rebecca come ho
detto prima amo questo personaggio e
quindi hanno approfittato visto che
aveva lo stesso look per aggirare altri
contenuti
sono le dieci di sera e ho appena
postato su instagram un video in cui e
riassumo il the best o prede ca con
alcune sue frasi sue citazioni della
serie in spagnolo ma con i sottotitoli
quindi mi raccomando andatelo a vedere
appena sente di vedere questo video
spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuta
questa tipologia di video mi raccomando
fatemi sapere
qui sotto se vi è piaciuto il video se
vi piacerebbe vederne altri di questo
tipo e soprattutto in chi prossimamente
vi piacerebbe kimi trasformati
ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale e di
seguirmi sia su tik tok che su instagram
perché come detto anche prima sto
pubblicando dantisti contenuti anche io
vi mando un bacione norme e ci vediamo
al prossimo video debutto madre tia
ciao